the water's still Sparkle here on the
Tana Kenya's longest river it's a
thousand kilometers long and provides
the basis of life for animals and humans
alike but some spots along the Tana have
dried up leaving just rocks and sand the
operator of a hydroelectric power plant
has diverted several kilometres of the
river to a nearby Dam through an
underground tunnel Marianna pious walks
two hours every day to fetch drinking
water for herself and her family of ten
she is outraged water used to flow along
here but then the first Dam was built
and it was reduced to a trickle after
the second Dam was built it disappeared
altogether Myesha lydia Alaka is here
for the first time the scientist works
for the university of nairobi wise up
project the goal of the project is to
defuse the conflict between the
different groups who use the water her
data is meant to help find sensible ways
of using the little water available what
is life there are two issues of just the
quantity of water so either a lot or too
little and then the other thing is the
quality issues that we have ADA water
that is of very poor quality and water
that is of good quality
and where there is no water conflicts
are escalating in recent years further
down the river fights over grazing land
and water have even resulted in death
some residents believe climate change is
the main culprit others blame the dams
nearly half of Kenya's electricity is
produced here making the dams crucial
for the country's industrial development
to understand the river or Larker
travels to one of its tributaries the
interests of the locals here are
different from what she's seen before
the people don't want to use the river
for industrial purposes but to preserve
nature because of the lose over the past
few years they've been planting forests
along the river it's a long-term project
supported by the government shade from
the trees should help prevent
evaporation of the river water 5-10
years from now this we had completed
right
completely there was no Prato but you
can see the water is now drawing the
locals shared their knowledge and
experience with the scientists they're
glad to talk about the project because
the forestation benefits everyone along
the river this is the dream do I would
clean clear like what we have seen here
that's something Marianna pious can only
dream about
she doesn't benefit from the
hydroelectric power plant
she doesn't have electricity she doesn't
care about that she just wants clean
water to get through the day